[Music]
remember you have to get the problem is
finding there okay so here I'm going to
turn this and you're gonna feel that
torque right I can't keep turning it the
tendons are starting to affect it right
well that's what you want you can get
that torch and that's gonna put a torque
in this elbow you can stand up feel it
more hug okay I'm starting in his
shoulder so there's now a torque in the
shoulder so I'm not if I let go of that
and I'm not pulling this so I get the
torque in his body and then you can
affect the shoulder through through his
Center at the foot so you get a pulldown
[Music]
so toward in his body and that affects
that if you're I want you to try to be
sensitive so that you can feel with your
with your hand holder becomes to that
okay and then it doesn't take much
on your pulse on your full-on I'm on the
pulse line with a young key ok right
there and then my finger my pinky I get
the torque in your body you feel it
today and now you're now you're a unit
and then I can drop this look to you
guys like I'm doing this right that you
can see how much I can make them go
forward
[Music]
see that machine is not it's not that
keep going keep training not there this
is her body's full of slack so your
connection to her you don't have one you
just connect up pulling and pushing
shoulders the arm does no Candice not in
the arm
then you hear it see this little this
little step that I take to the outside
that's what makes her arm to pitch
you're not you don't want to go like
this I know I'm not enough it's not a
network it's only about right so when I
go like this and then I have not enough
you can't go even when you go back and
once you once you understand this then
you don't need the grip you just need
that that tightness okay boom you got it
you know so you Yuri oh I don't have it
so I'm going to start Lucy my trip for
those that are getting it just attorney
so this hand isn't turn it anymore
that's not very Marshall but more keep
keeping the angles because I only yes I
only need a fraction of a second so my
body is moving and then I have it in his
arm say you don't you don't need to be
stronger than him you just keep that
angle going okay
[Music]
I'm keeping that sensitive torque that
torque in there but I'm not doing it
with turning now
[Music]
you just pushing the right you had some
projection but it's not 200 are his arms
got a lot of slack because you're
opening that angle too much the elbow
angles too much and you're on the
outside of his arm you need to be on the
inside of the John that's awfully high
and his elbows down there's not gonna be
torquing for awfully high your hands
knees hands near his shoulder if you're
on the outside of his arm so there's no
way you're doing it right you're doing
all external stuff so try to get and
just use you be your own weight for her
height it's just too heavy for that
stuff you can't do it
go grab his mouth line it's too high and
now you opened it you opened his elbows
so you lost the torque on his arm
so it's very much akin to you want to
get stronger with your chest right you
do your bench press okay what if you buy
a bar that's made of paper and every
time you push the bar breaks you get it
the resistance is not going to be there
for you to get the training that you
want because you need to have the
stressor the stressing element in order
to call it the adaptation you guys
understand that okay so if my if my your
kid just he wants to always do a step
back back break fall you understand
and he that's what he's gonna do every
time you can even since he's doing it
any time no matter what I'm doing right
why don't you do it before I even do
anything
got a go and that's like my paper bar
just broke on me and I don't get any
training okay so you why do they do that
that why did it do that how do you mean
you're not quite understanding right
you see now I this was a paper bar I'm
not a stressor I'm not causing an
adaptation but why am i doing hey that's
a lot easier for me that goes with my
emotional state
look hey when you throw me I'm out of
control and it makes me scared so I'm
going to control it and he so what did
you do as you can you take away the
stressor you're not you're not adapting
you're not going to find the adaptation
so he has to he has to hang out even if
I go slow he has to not want to fall you
got it
don't fall then I can't get the
adaptation so we have certain rules his
rule is he has to keep a full grip he
has to meet his assigned tasks right so
he has because Luca has their own
learning elements he has to match into
young right when he throws himself go
she's not matching it you know so he's
not even learning to suit kids right so
he has to hang out there so I can go
slow right we can go slow we don't have
to go fast like the last reps but he has
to hang out and I had to be able to
displace his mouth as some of you
noticed when you vote for manukan who's
throwing themselves to one who's not and
you try to push him you bounce off
because you'll have grounding so you're
just making yourself winter he's gonna
hang out he has he goes keep his head
off the mat and he lets what happens to
his body happens see that was fine
[Music]
even if you're not training fast still
better training then she comes in and
throws himself and you know you're not
do it just go down that's not it
okay I'll do it this is Joe that's a
paper barb no-go torque and into his
body immediately like this I asked you
guys hey go slow then and then then you
can not work out and do your arm you see
that so I really don't have time you
think they hit that arm so what I'm
doing is boom okay
I got connection but I didn't do the
throw yet you see that and then I get my
bouquet at that time to get ready
you understand that right so here move
got it and then try to get that
okay they also don't ask a lot of it it
says he's a Kazushi do you understand
that so I go boom got it that's all I
needed
then he would key calendars right so he
wants to get his balance back so that
now it's can't go back so find my feet
we could even be here all day
unless I can ground better than him
which I probably can because of his
posture right but once so I can't go in
once he once he goes and counters here
this race what I would do then look you
how big in space okay so you have your
initial boom Kazushi again you think and
if that's what I'm feeling so counter
counter and you're in free my feet we
mess it okay if you're on the other side
of the barn I'll stick with the same
side let me do I'm getting all the way
on the other side you see I'm going to
go again right here so don't have much
room that's all I need it boom
okay let's try it play with it